je jure que si la femme veut être belle
ou si elle met tout son soin le paraître
en sortant et satyfend c'est pour
guerroyer contre chasteté chasteté a
beaucoup d'ennemis dans les cloître et
les abbayes elles sont toutes liguées
contre elles et ne seront jamais si en
murés qu'elle ne cherche qu'à là au nirv
vous venez d'entendre un extrait du
roman de la Rose écrit à quatre mains au
13e siècle par Guillaume de Loris né
près d'Orléans et par Jean demain né ici
même à main sur Loire tout à l'heure
nous irons d'ailleurs au château de main
sur Loire évoquée François Villon poète
de la fin du Moyen-Âge mais d'abord
décryptant ce roman majeur avec
l'université est spécialiste de
littérature médiévale Philippe Aujard
[Musique]
bonjour Philippe Aujard bonjour je
présentais ce roman de la Rose de façon
un peu anachronique tout à l'heure comme
issu de deux personnages il est d'abord
écrit par Guillaume de Loris donc Loris
la commune le village à l'époque de la
forêt d'Orléans et par Jean demain nous
sommes à sur Loire qui lui est un
bourgeois qui écrit la seconde partie à
vrai dire il en écrit les trois quarts
en quoi ces deux personnages sont-ils
majeurs et les cris le Roman de la Rose
et d'ailleurs se connaissent-ils alors
se connaissent-ils nous n'avons aucune
certitude ce que l'on sait c'est que
Jean de main écrit après Guillaume de
Loris en fait Jean De Man nous informe
que Guillaume de Loris est décédé avant
sa propre naissance à lui alors d'abord
c'est un long poème c'est un long poème
de 22 000 verres à peu près et
c'est donc composé de deux parties alors
la première partie composée par
Guillaume Deloris est important parce
que et cette partie est assez
emblématique de ce que l'on appelle la
littérature courtoise du début du 13e
siècle jeandemain décide de prolonger ce
récit resté inachevé sous la plume de
Jean demain le Roman de la Rose devient
une œuvre philosophique devient une
oeuvre encyclopédique dans laquelle
l'auteur Jean de main fait étalage un
peu de son savoir alors il exprime son
génie par exemple
laquelle a fait scandale a été très
largement discutée au 14e mais une
manifeste aussi son point de vue sur les
conditions sociales et une manifeste
aussi son anticléricalisme d'époque de
l'époque alors je vous propose de
cheminer maintenant vers le château nous
allons parler d'un autre écrivain alors
de la fin du Moyen-Âge il s'agit de
François Villon poète maudit ou alors
escroc
bonjour Xavier le lever alors évidemment
avant d'aller voir dans les jaunes dans
quelles conditions rude était détenu le
pauvre François Villon je voudrais que
vous nous disiez quelques mots de cette
ancienne forteresse construite il me
semble à partir du 13e siècle exactement
on est en 1209 et on a la résidence des
évêques d'Orléans qui s'installe ici à
Meung-sur-Loire et l'évêque d'Orléans à
tous les pouvoirs ici il a un pouvoir
spirituel un pouvoir temporel puisqu'il
est seigneur demain il va toucher les
octroies sur le pont notamment il a des
terres jusqu'à Montargis c'est une
grande puissance il est directement
associé au roi de France et donc
l'évêque d'Orléans c'est aussi la
justice du roi de France raison pour
laquelle le pauvre François Villand nous
attend dans les jaunes là-bas
[Musique]
ah oui effectivement le lieu est peu
agréable et il devait l'être moins
encore en 1461 lorsque François Villon
est détenu ici dans les jaunes du
château de main sur Loire on va rappeler
d'abord Philippe augeort qui est
François Villon que l'on peut présenter
comme le poète du temps c'est le poète
du temps avec d'autres bien sûr mais il
a pour lui d'être reconnu très
rapidement dans l'histoire de la de la
poésie
il a laissé une oeuvre qui n'est pas
très abondante mais en plus du de
l'oeuvre elle-même la personnalité a
marqué les esprits puisque le personnage
disparaît des radars pour parler de
façon moderne deux ans après son
élargissement de la prison de
Meung-sur-Loire on a plus aucune trace
de François Villon à partir de 63 1460
et dites moi c'est du pain béni pour
vous ça cette anecdote sur François
Villon ici au château de Meung-sur-Loire
oui alors n'est pas hyper connu c'est
clair mais en tout cas nous c'est une
grande fierté d'avoir un poète comme ça
c'est un bonhomme qui considérant que
vous inviter à relire du François Villon
alors dans du français contemporain
parce qu'en vieux François on ne connaît
plus rien mais vous avez une énergie je
pense souvent à François ayant quand on
parle de la Renaissance et le début
d'une pensée avec une énergie la
difficulté des Trump sur terre
absolument merveilleux on est très fiers
nous d'avoir eu François Villon ici et
donc François Villon est libéré au bout
de quatre mois en 1461 en octobre 1461
directement sous on va dire Louis XI
prend cette décision exactement à
l'occasion de sa visite donc dans ma
bonne ville de Meung-sur-Loire et on
connaît l'attachement de Louis X puisque
il est enterré pas très loin d'ici à
Cléry-Saint-André
avant de vous quitter je ne résiste pas
à l'envie de vous citer un dernier
extrait du roman de la Rose qu'il faut
lire avec un petit sourire coquin aux
lèvres
avant que je partisse de ces lieux où je
fusse encore demeurer volontiers je
cueillis à grande joie la fleur du beau
rosier feuillus et jus la rose vermeille
alors il fit jour et je m'éveillais